i realized that i was carrying so much
of what wasn't mine and like through
doing therapy like i realized like okay
that's not mine that's not mine cake
this is mine
this is my so like i think now like
i just kind of like try to sit with
myself if i'm like feeling an
overwhelming amount of emotion and try
to understand like okay whose is this
like is this mine is this new tending to
or should i put this should i give this
back to like its rightful owner because
i i do carry a lot of stuff um and i
guess that just comes with like feeling
guilty a lot like i hold a lot of guilt
for things i
i guess i've just been programmed over
the years to like i don't know just
carry a lot of shame and guilt and feel
bad for decisions that i've made and
stuff and
um i'm sure that'll come somewhere i
don't know i don't know that's i again
like i because i just need to like
please people and make sure that
everybody's okay if i if i feel like in
any way i contributed even the smallest
amount to someone's pain or to saying no
to somebody or hurting someone in any
way like it really
i spiral like at the thought of of
hurting anybody and because of that i
just carry all this guilt and then i
carry guilt and shame for
um like a huge part of it was like
feeling guilty about having these
negative emotions and feeling depressed
and anxious when my life on paper is so
wonderful you know there's a lot of
shame that came with that and like shame
i always say is like such a pointless
emotion and guilt is such a pointless
emotion because
you can't do anything with it it just
kind of sits there and festers there's
no real
use for it you know even anger and
sadness there's like some use for that
but guilt and shame is just a really
bad emotion that you gotta you know get
out of your system um and like train
yourself out of but it's very hard to do
um so i find myself carrying it a lot of
the time brilliant reasons
really if i'm using my own experience of
what my lesson was and what i would do
too much of i was so afraid of being
alone
and
um
i i realized that the i was and i was so
afraid of not being chosen
and my lesson was i was supposed to be
choosing myself
yeah so if i use that in this scenario
like the way that you
are doing that for other people the care
that you have for other people
is what you're supposed to be doing for
yourself 100
yeah yeah and these people are all just
showing you that they're just they're
just showing you they're your mirror to
show you like you're carrying so much
you're carrying you're here they're just
showing you this pattern over and over
and over again and really it's like for
you to do for yourself and so your inner
child right now is like jumping through
damn hula hoops right now and it's like
yeah yeah yeah hi that's me
yeah 100 yeah going back to the same
thing that i was saying it's like i
always thought like
you know
people
make me do like feel certain ways
they're like you know nobody like gives
me the same love that i give them like
i'm always giving so much to people and
they're always so selfish and they don't
you know give me the same love back or
the same courtesy back and it's like
instead of thinking of it that way just
think of well why am i giving so much to
them and not enough to myself like what
these people are doing is giving
themselves the love that i should be
giving myself you know it's not like
they should be giving me more love i
should be giving myself more love so
it's the same thing that's another huge
mirror for me it's like nobody makes you
feel certain ways or like sometimes it's
not other people's fault it's just you
need to readjust the way that you are
living and what you're giving to
yourself versus what you're giving to
others and like how much of that
you want to give to either side you know
um so yeah it ultimately was like my my
choice and it's not a bad thing to to
you know sometimes like especially as
women i feel like we put such a negative
connotation on being selfish or on you
know giving love to yourself and and
feeling confident in yourself i feel
like it's almost not allowed and again
there's so much guilt and shame around
doing things for yourself or or feeling
confident in yourself you know it's like
we're supposed to like downplay our
accomplishments and downplay
compliments and stuff and um it's just a
way that we've been like taught and
raised and i i'm trying really
consciously nowadays to not do that and
to like accept compliments willingly and
openly without shutting them down or
without like you know turning it on its
head was like a a negative thing about
myself or blowing it off in some way or
yeah you know it's so helpful to
picture it like the way that something
happens in interaction you picture okay
would i ever let them like i'm allowing
it for myself which is the [ __ ] we
do to ourselves but i would never allow
this for my inner child the same thing
comes in the other direction with the
compliments it's like try and imagine it
being told to your inner child you'd be
like hell yeah she's awesome or whatever
it is you know that's a good way because
it's such a good way to bridge the gap
between
your
higher self or your intuition your inner
child is to to pretend like it's
separate but but it's not and it sort of
helps to close that gap in your heart
between you and you a hundred percent
yeah totally
totally i feel like that's been so
effective in
healing that and healing her and healing
me
um
yeah for sure